hello my name is victoria and i just
graduated from the university of
virginia
i'm about to start my first year
teaching in a public school
um i never thought i would have to you
know weigh my options on going to a
private or public based on being
you know in this situation with crt and
teachers being forced not to teach
so given that i don't want to give up on
public school
what advice might you have for me and
second where do you see
this fight going and how could the
public schools return back to normalcy
arithmetic reading writing
yeah i mean so i i think there are a few
things here one just on a personal job
level
moving to a right-to-work state is
probably a good idea uh with regard to
public schools public school teachers
you know the the aft and the nea are
just disastrous areas
they're some of the worst unions in
america they're just garbage uh
if you know if you are insistent on on
remaining in virginia
uh and operating you know in the in the
context of the their public schools
the good news is that a lot of the local
school boards are really pushing back
and providing information to the local
school boards and to the citizenry at
large as to what's happening inside the
the classroom
is really really important we get leaks
at daily wear every day and we're able
to really
push those pretty hard i mean it was it
was a reporter
from uh from our website actually uh who
was
reporting first on sort of the the
uprising in loudoun county that has
turned into such a major issue i'm
teaching and learning yeah exactly so
so loud and county there's real pushback
and that that is absolutely wonderful
um i i also think that there's going to
be a lot of support for if teachers
end up being fired over this sort of
stuff i think there's going to be a lot
of support for those teachers being able
to teach in private schools with with
subsidies too
i think there's there's a lot of public
support for teachers who are
willing to do that sort of thing but i
think that the blowback on crt is
happening i think it is quite real the
polling data shows that it is extremely
unpopular
and i think that as long as parents stay
active and teachers are a big part of
that because again
most parents have no transparency as to
what's happening in the classroom
teachers who convey that whether it is
through leaks or whether it is or
whether it is publicly are doing the
world of favor